we're going to stay focused on what
could be a historic leak of an even more
historic draft opinion signaling that
the supreme court may be set to overturn
roe v wade the opinion was first
obtained by politico and it's attributed
to justice samuel alito who writes quote
row and casey must be overruled the
constitution makes no reference to
abortion and no such right is implicitly
protected by any constitutional
provision he goes on to write roe was
egregiously wrong from the start close
quote democratic senator amy klobuchar
joins us now from capitol hill she
serves on the senate judiciary committee
uh senator good morning this breaking
news overnight
much later than i expected to be and i'm
sure that's true for a lot of other
americans yourself included
we heard from judge alito in this
apparent draft opinion why do you think
he's wrong in other words why do you
think there is in fact a constitutional
right to abortion access
well tony this was a shocker and we know
it's a leaked opinion as you know we
don't know what the final opinion will
be
but what basically the court would be
doing would be overturning 50 years of
precedence something that has been on
the books that women have relied on that
75 to 80 percent of the public support
and says should not be overturned
so clearly they are inserting their own
political judgments for what has been
the law of the land and by the way
if you look at what he says abortion the
word's not in the constitution well
birth control is not in the constitution
and that also uses a similar argument in
past cases for a right to privacy
the term marriage gay marriage is not in
the constitution the court has
interpreted the constitution to protect
these rights for americans so that is
why this is such a big deal and we
already tony have
over a dozen states that have automatic
triggers that are going to ban abortion
if in fact this opinion is issued and
many many more that have laws on the
books that will most likely ban it
yeah the implications are huge center it
would be the state or the government
requiring a woman to take a pregnancy to
term that is just a very big deal in
this country
i want to ask about another line in the
draft opinion that says
the decision on abortion access should
be put in the hands of the people's
representatives in other words you and
and your fellow members of congress what
are you planning to do if this draft
becomes reality
okay so
let me first comment on that i think
most women this is why you see 80
percent of the people supporting not
overturning this
most women say i would rather have this
be a decision between me
my family and my doctor my doctor i want
this to be a decision between me and my
doctor not ted cruz okay but that is
exactly what the court will be doing by
handing it back to elected officials all
over the country so what can we do in
washington we can actually put roe v
wade into law codify roe v wade we have
many many votes of course on the
democratic side for that we do have a
few and now let me emphasize few
pro-choice republicans probably two in
the senate but again unless you do
something about the filibuster that i
have long supported eliminating
um we would not have the votes to over
to basically
enshrine the protections of roe v wade
into law so now we're going to have a
patchwork of state laws so to me we will
do all we can to do this maybe we will
get more republicans but most likely
this will end up at the ballot box that
is why this fall when voters go to vote
and my prediction tony is now women are
going to go to vote in numbers we have
never seen before because we've never
seen
such in our lifetimes such an
overturning a major precedent as this
and if they want to protect their
fundamental rights to reproductive
choice or their fundamental rights to
anything they had better go and vote in
the fall
senator klobuchar even if people do go
in support of protecting
abortion rights and procedures
what more can be done by
representatives at this point if you're
expecting that it will be overturned and
what do you say to people who are
concerned uh and those who are rejoicing
this morning
well first of all i think we need to
once again bring the women's protection
health protection act up for a vote that
would guarantee that roe v wade would be
the law of the land and as i've said our
republican colleagues have very sadly
for the women of america
been blocking that from coming up to a
vote but i
i believe we need to immediately call it
up for a vote again it has passed in the
house of representatives and it's time
in the senate to call it up for a vote
the other thing that can happen is it's
state legislatures across the country
the fight will be fought
this will of course result in a
patchwork of laws but for anyone that's
just been believing that we can sit on
our laurels of a 50-year opinion that
all the work from the past
is behind us it's not in fact the work
has just begun i remember once barbara
mikulski who was the dean of the women
of the senate would always say
suit up um suit up
put your shoulders straight put your
lipstick on and get ready for a fight
because that is exactly what's gonna
happen with the women of america and we
simply can't let this court which is so
out of step with the people of america
and if this leaked opinion is true they
are literally overturning a 50 years of
precedent
if with a case that is supported by 80
of the american public just because they
have their own personal political views
because you can and we have no idea what
floodgate will be open on birth control
and the like uh we have republican uh
legislators that are talking about
six-week fan on abortion this is going
to be complete chaos if this goes
through
senator klobuchar you mentioned the
american people and wishful thinking is
we agree upon a law and there's
uniformity across the country that's not
the case so with that said previous
polling shows that majority of people
from certain states they are against
abortion so there is a thought out there
that if that is the case then why
shouldn't abortion laws just be left up
to the states what do you say to that
okay nate well first of all the numbers
nationwide are somewhere between 75 to
80 percent of the people poll and poll
again have shown that 75 to 80 percent
of the people believe that a woman
should have the right to make her own
decisions reproductive decisions
different states of course you're going
to get different numbers but the beauty
of having this done through a court
opinion because it was seen as such a
fundamental right written a case written
by a republican appointed supreme court
justice justice blackman 50 years ago
he looked at it and he said look i was
appointed by a republican but i believe
when i look at the constitution and what
has been happening in america that this
is a fundamental right just like birth
control was found to be a fundamental
right the world changes and it's the
supreme court's job to interpret the
laws as there are the constitution as it
is to see if it includes fundamental
rights that's what gay marriage was all
about so if this court is going to turn
back the clock and take away all of
these rights that have been considered
in well-thought-out cases we have
basically a revolution going on when it
comes to women's rights and people are
going to have to go to the ballot box
and make that decision and yeah you're
right those states will have the
opportunity to do that some of them
already have like texas where they've
established bounty hunters so you can
tell on your neighbor and call them out
i just don't think that's the future we
want
yeah senator it certainly does change
the politics of the midterm uh that
that's for sure it's 50 years now almost
of a guaranteed constitutional right of
access to abortion in this country which
may end uh in the not-too-distant future
thank you for crystallizing the
conversation for us senator klobuchar
appreciate it thank you